Well,
there are lots of indications that there
still racism in American society.
If we look at overall indicators for
life chances,
a life expectancy in comm wealth,
educational attainment and performance
within schools,
we still see discernible differences in
performance between whites and Asians
and blacks and Latinos in the United
States.
Uh,
some of those differences are attributed
to systemic or structural factors.
And to the extent that we can explain
those differences by systemic
instructional factors and we can,
that is evidence of racism in American
society.
In addition,
while we don't see a lot of the racial
violence that we saw a century ago,
we still see examples of overt racial
violence in the United States today.
For instance,
uh,
the southern poverty law center has just
released a report that indicates that
there is a lot of racial violence in the
south directed towards Latinos,
um,
under the guise of xenophobia and anti
immigration stances.
And so when we see these things
happening,
when we see news incidences,
um,
on the rise in 2007 towards African
Americans,
we can still say that there still
bigotry,
racism and prejudice and American
society
well indicates tremendous progress.
It demonstrates the power and influence
of the African American vote.
And it's a remarkable that African
Americans have been able to exercise
their,
a political influence in such a way 40
years after the passage of the voting
rights act.
Now 44 years after the passage of the
voting rights act.
Um,
it is a testament to the increasing
tolerance of nonblack communities and
putting their faith in confidence in
someone like Barack Obama to be their
president of the United States.
If we look at other candidacies for the
presidency,
for instance,
Jesse Jackson's a Democratic candidate
sees in 1984,
1988 people were not prepared to elect
an African American president at that
time.
So the fact that Obama was able to make
it past the nomination stage and to win
the presidency shows tremendous racial
progress in this country.
A post racial society should we ever
get,
there would be a society where when
social scientists like me run our models
and we include a race as a dummy
variable races no longer hours,
typically significant,
uh,
and we're just not there yet.
So anytime we run a model,
we see significant differences,
uh,
in that some of the indicators that I
mentioned before,
education and calm life expectancy,
a probability of going to jail,
other types of things.
And once those things are no longer
being predicted by race,
then we can say that we're in a post
racial society.
But until then,
um,
people's race stills actually very
significant in their lives.
And as an aside for the president,
um,
most people argue that his race wasn't a
hindrance to him.
And in fact,
it may have been a help to him.
Um,
racism and racial stereotyping cut both
ways.
Uh,
it can cut in negative ways and it can
cut in positive ways.
And so in many ways,
President Obama represented the
exception that proved the rule.
That's still the notion of race in our
society and it's still reifies negative
stereotypes towards African Americans.
And while it makes us feel good,
um,
and it may make us feel progressive or
liberal or cosmopolitan,
there's still some underlying racial
prejudice that goes into the attitude
and we need to be very mindful of that.
I think as post racialism is being
constructed in popular media today,
I think it does actually have,
uh,
the,
potential to water down diversity and,
um,
helps to obscure the need to appreciate
people's diversity.
Um,
oftentimes people will be indeed the
term post racialism during the last
election as a shortcut to be able to not
deal with a persistent racism in
American society.
I actually wrote about this in the
Washington Post and got attacked for it.
Um,
so,
uh,
people could say,
I voted for Barack Obama,
therefore I am not prejudiced.
I voted for Barack Obama.
Therefore there's no racism in American
society anymore.
You know,
one historic election while important.
Um,
and while pivotal is not necessarily a
sign that we have completely turned the
corner and we always have to be vigilant
about,
uh,
our own prejudices,
our own attitudes,
and this goes for minorities and non
minorities,
a light to be able to be on our guard to
recognize that we're all capable of
slipping back into old patterns of
action.
If we declare 2009 the post racial age
in America,
we end up sort of failing to recognize
that we are all still human and that we
are all still very susceptible to
allowed really bad attitudes towards
other groups.
Black leadership today looking at the
people who have been dubbed post racial
leaders in American society,
people like President Obama,
people like governor deval Patrick or
Mayor Cory Booker,
Adrian fenty or congressmen,
Archer Davis or Harold Ford owe a debt
of gratitude to the African American
forebearers who came before them,
who were not always welcome in
mainstream political circles,
who are perceived as being racialized,
who are often defined in direct
opposition to this young Khadra of
leadership.
And,
and most of them do recognize that they
owe a debt of gratitude to the
trailblazing steps that,
uh,
those,
forefathers and foremothers made for
them.
Um,
in terms of the current electoral system
in which many young black politicians
are running,
they do,
um,
really seek out alliances with Latinos
in their communities.
And so we know in this past election
that one of the things that Health
Barack Obama and his quest for the
presidency was increased a democratic
voting amongst Latinos.
And so for the previous two election
cycles,
we had seen,
uh,
Latinos,
um,
identifying increasingly with the
Republican Party in terms of their vote.
We saw that tide switch and it was
actually going back to more normal
historic levels of voting behavior.
Most Latinos,
um,
there are a lot of cities where there
are blacks and Latinos who live side by
side and where both groups make up a
significant portion of the population.
And you do need a Latino support in
order to create a multiracial coalition
that puts blacks and office.
So to that extent,
yes.
Um,
there are some cities where a,
you don't see blacks and Latinos living
in the same space or in the same
political jurisdiction.
And so those alliances are less salient
and,
and those uh,
races.
But you know,
in most races you do need abroad and
multiracial coalition and that certainly
includes Latinos.
I studied African American leadership
and particularly interested in questions
of generational transition amongst
African Americans.
So I'm interested in black politicians
born after 1960.
What are the implications for having
been born after the civil rights
movement,
having been the beneficiary of the civil
rights movement in terms of being able
to run for political office,
um,
and being able to change the landscape
of what we usually consider an African
American political agenda.
Um,
so this has led to me editing one book
coming out later this year called who's
black politics cases in post racial
black leadership.
And I just received a contract for my
book that focuses on Newark,
New Jersey called Newark and the clash
of two Black Americas.
Um,
with respect or relating to these
issues.
I am interested in the intersection of
race and class in particular.
And looking at class based politics.
So usually we think about African
American politics,
um,
in terms of a deep political unity.
So we look at the fact that 90% of
African Americans usually vote
democratic and presidential elections.
That was 95% in 2008.
And we look at partisan identification
in the African American community being
about 80% democratic.
And so people assume that blacks were
monolithic political group.
We've always known that that wasn't
true,
but they're generally forces such as
discrimination and racism that have
compelled African Americans to close
ranks politically.
So my questions tend to ask,
well,
what happens within this democratic
coalition when you have African
Americans who represent different
political agendas,
who represent different political areas
and who are very explicitly represent
different types of class politics.
What's the impact on what we think of as
that classic African American Political
Agenda?
Or we're talking about reducing
inequality,
addressing poverty,
how to address poverty,
in what ways to frame that.
And so there's definitely a generational
battle within African American
communities over these issues.
And there's been this long standing,
um,
discussion about the efficacy of
adopting what we would call d racialized
politics and political science.
But what I think most journalists are
calling post racial politics.
So the politics of racial transcendence,
not necessarily making explicit racial
appeals to African American communities.
There are lots of people who are very
concerned that when candidates do not
talk about race on the campaign trail,
that they are hamstrung from being able
to address race any very forceful and
explicit way once they're in office.
Now that we have a critical mass of a
quote unquote post racial young black
political leaders who have used these
deviation racial strategies to in top is
we now are going to be in a position to
be able to test a whether or not they
are effective in their office,
whether they are more effective than
there are black predecessors.
Um,
and whether or not we can actually
advance that classic African American
political agenda going forward.